hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for another exclusive collider
interview i am perry and emroff and
right now i get to talk to
william zapka from karate kid and cobra
kai
it is so good to see you i am so excited
for all the good things coming your way
right now
thank you so much good to see you good
to be here so
i guess let's just start with some of
the biggest news of the bunch the move
to netflix i am curious what it was like
going through all that from
your perspective were were you just
completely in the dark until the deal
was done
well no we had a little idea going
through first of all we pitched it
originally to netflix was one of our
our pitches that we we went on and we
almost landed in netflix at the
beginning and youtube grabbed it
uh so netflix was always in the cards um
but once
youtube decided they weren't doing the
uh the original content anymore
uh for scripted uh then it just went out
into a free fall for it for so to speak
so it was like december 19th i got the
news that they weren't picking it up
and uh it was about i don't know five
six months then uh
and we found out but we heard little
tricks along the way there were a lot of
people you know there was hulu i think
interested in and uh along you know hbo
max whatever
and uh so when we got to netflix it was
kind of uh
kind of our dream from the beginning and
it's come full circle so it's awesome
i imagine that it was probably a hot
property for just about everyone out
there
was was there ever a point when you guys
were actually
worried that it wouldn't find a new home
especially with some of season three
maybe having been shot by then
well it's just such a trying time right
now so we didn't know what the market
was going to do
but we uh we had hope i mean i remember
when the guys
john josh and hayden called me told me
about uh
youtube not picking it up he said but
there's a silver lining it could go
somewhere else and don't forget cobra
kai never dies so
you know we had a feeling that uh it
would march on
but you know there's no guarantees until
it happens and it was down to the wire
it really was
down to the wire and when they made
their deal
and uh we got the call and uh it was
very exciting you know you
sony was in in touch with us telling us
the progression and how things were
going and
but we were you know we were we had no
guarantees for sure so
landed there is awesome i'm so thrilled
that it landed at such a good home i'm
obviously a huge fan of netflix and i
feel like it's the perfect place to get
an even wider viewership than you guys
already have
yeah i think so i mean we already have a
big fan base which is incredible but
they have you know another
you know they have kind of a global
market the world and 195 million
subscribers so
i know the show has been translated into
30 some languages
a lot of people that have been able to
see it globally are getting a chance to
watch the first two seasons so uh we're
excited about that
i didn't even think about that part of
it that is that's a phenomenal perk
there
yeah so i want to kind of hit
all the stages of this franchise for you
and first i have a karate kid
question for you but a very very
specific one i was wondering if you
remember what it was like
filming the moment where johnny
hands daniel the trophy because i know
it's only one line of dialogue there but
it's kind of a line of dialogue that has
to capture their entire
journey in the film in that one little
moment so
even with everything going on around you
guys during that scene
do you have time to really perfect the
delivery of something like that
well you know what it's more than
delivery that was the kind of the belly
of the whale of johnny that was like
that was the billy in johnny really that
was the part of the script when i read
uh the karate kid and i read johnny
lawrence it really wasn't until
uh chris said sweep the leg and johnny
didn't want to do it
and uh the ending when he says you're
all right lou was a good match
and um so i was kind of pregnant with
that moment
for the entire time we were filming it
you know knowing that was coming i
it allowed me to be you know as vicious
and mean and tough and
uh you know uh as johnny as i
as i could be till the end and then
johnny wakes up so when we film that i
remember filming that moment like it was
yesterday it was just
it was after the whole tournament and it
was after we did this big master shot of
the full-on fight you know it wasn't
shot in pieces it was 910 cameras around
and
the tournament we went from a to z and
uh that moment was captured um i think
in the
one of the master takes and it was just
alive and
the fans you know the the audience that
audience fans were there and
uh all that added energy and electricity
to that moment and the emotion plus my
mom and dad
were in the stands and i remember when i
was doing the the fight scene i was on
my knees when they said turn around you
know and daniel was hurt and
everybody was booing at me even when the
cameras weren't rolling i look up in the
in the stands and my mom's like it's my
son he's a nice guy
you know so it's kind of carrying a lot
of emotion it was very like the
the audience there was like live live
theater and they were all part of it
and um so they fed that moment so i
remember that and it was very much of a
cathartic moment for me as an actor to
to let that go because that to me was
the true heart of johnny lawrence
it seems like such a wonderful luxury to
be able to shoot a scene like that that
way
have you guys been able to take anything
as far as the production goes that
really worked for you
on karatekid and apply it even to a
modern production today
i mean it's a little different i mean it
was we shot a little more in blocks in
our final tournament scene
we did the karate kid john appleton had
cameras everywhere was really like a big
microphone and a videotape you know film
camera filming everything um
yeah we take a little bit of it but uh
it's it's a new style i think a little
bit we have so many fights and so many
moves
so it's not as shot as that but uh but
it's got the same spirit that's for sure
oh absolutely so now going to the very
beginning
of cobra kai because i know you guys got
pitched revivals kind of
often so i don't know how many specifics
you remember but what would you say is
just like
like the craziest most out of left field
pitch
to return to the role of johnny you got
along the way
oh i had so many so many people had
ideas for johnny lawrence teaming up
with miyagi actually you know what my
favorite one was
really was pat morita himself had an
idea he wasn't done with miyagi yet
and this was in his uh you know last
years and uh
he called me he said bzbz i've got a
great idea for karate kid four you know
i've tried to get five you know
you know and i want miyagi's gonna die
and he wanted him to
have a proper okinawan burial but while
he's sick he saw johnny lawrence as
being his doctor
and um i thought that was interesting so
that was kind of actually
probably the one the wildest idea i
couldn't imagine
coming from pat marie it was awesome uh
but these guys uh you know
i i even played with trying to find
something that was
you know how do you johnny lawrence kind
of never died the karate kid never went
away how do we
you know there's got to be some creative
angle in and um i played a little bit
with that on this music video i directed
called sweep the leg
by no more kings i played myself trapped
as johnny but uh john josh and hayden
our creators of the show came and they
just had
they had the map of where uh karate kid
goes from here
and they laid it out and i walked away
from that meeting and uh
i i i felt like uh the johnny lawrence
and me opened one crusty eye
you know and uh they were bringing them
back to life and uh
and they did that so it was really the
right guys in the right timing
and um you know and then ralph jumped in
and
and uh we went for it now here we are
i actually have a good follow-up but
it's not from me so
as press we get the opportunity to kind
of grill you guys
all the time but i recently spoke to
mary and she had a question that she
hasn't had the opportunity to ask you
that she wants to pass along
my question i haven't ever asked and i
meant to ask early on
but i've always felt to like you know
like oh that's not my place i feel a
little scared uh
even though he's like the nicest guy
ever is probably like
how much of like his johnny now
he had thought about in the years
between
before somebody approached him about
having his own storyline so i know he
had his own version when he filmed the
karate kid
of who he believed johnny was and he had
created johnny to be
but like how much of that thought
process had gone in
in those in between years or just when
somebody gave him that opportunity is
that when
then when the process started of
thinking about okay yeah that's how this
aspect plays into this
first of all mary you should have asked
me yourself uh
you know the johnny that's in cobra kai
i i
probably would have resisted and i would
not have imagined johnny that way to me
at the end
johnny was liberated he probably found a
good path so my imagination and i never
really filled the blanks in but i i
wouldn't have imagined him being
you know in the in the beer in a
one-bedroom apartment and you know kind
of stuck in the past
too much so uh but the johnny that lives
in me the kind of
the character the essence of him uh was
right there
ready to reach so uh i hadn't thought
about it this way this is this is credit
to the writers and uh
you know i just connected my heart and
the character of johnny to the writing
and we have uh
johnny lawrence today you feel it i was
wondering if there's anything
from the original karate kid that didn't
make
the final cut that you think might come
in handy
on cobra kai because i know you guys
were able to use different angles for
the fight
in the beginning of the series i don't
know whether it's
material like that unused footage
deleted scenes even ideas that you had
brewing in your brain
that you didn't have time to execute in
that movie is there anything you would
want to bring to future seasons
well i know there's a there's a couple
seas scenes that were completely cut out
of the karate kid one is referenced i
think in season two
um involving an apple pie
or a blueberry pie yeah that was a scene
that we shot that was uh
that was pretty fun and then and then
the scene that i auditioned for the
movie was cut out and that's a scene
right before the tournament
uh at school and that's when i walk up
to daniel at a water fountain at school
and they hand him a death certificate
and he says what's this for i say you
got to get your miami to sign it
if you want to be in the tournament with
the big boys and he looks at it it's a
death certificate he says i thought it
was supposed to be no contact
and i say yeah well accidents happen and
then i turn and walk away and he says
hey you think he might be wrong
and i say who he says your sensei you
think he might be wrong
and then my line is to walk up and grab
them and go watch your mouth [ __ ]
and so that was the scene that i
auditioned for for the movie we shot
that
um i don't know if that's going to pop
up somewhere in uh in the future in a
flashback or what but uh
that was a that was the scene that uh i
auditioned for i rehearsed uh
for weeks and weeks and weeks till i got
the part and then
ironically that scene was cut from the
film it's a mighty dark thing to happen
but also i would expect something like
that on cobra kai because you guys
really i mean not to get too far into
season two yet but you guys
really shocked me in a good way with how
far you push it at the end of season two
just like the intensity is through the
roof yes
yes i agree overall in cobra kai one of
my absolute favorite things about the
show
is how big the ensemble is and
how i think there is a character that
can strike a chord for just about
every viewer out there so
for you having read the script before
even shooting jumping on set
who would you say surprised you most
with what they did as far as taking what
was on the page and bringing it to
screen and going kind of above and
beyond your expectations with the part
honestly everybody we did chemistry
readings i know that's a safe answer but
truly you know uh these parts were
written for people to fill them up and
embody these characters and
um so uh i was
you know they're wonderful young actors
and actors in the show and
and to watch them flourish and embrace
these characters and make them them
reminded me of when i was a kid when i
was 17 18 and
and i took johnny on and put the suit on
for the first time so
to watch them and then essentially
especially to watch them grow over the
the seasons um is is awesome i wouldn't
say it's surprising but it's
encouraging and exciting and uh you see
these guys rising to this level and it
makes this
like you said this ensemble this great
kind of choir
you know and with many themes weaving
through it and many story lines and you
kind of care about each character and
you're invested in everybody you can
look through everybody's point of view
so um everybody nailed it and i'm proud
of everybody it's a smart answer to
spread the love to everyone because
that's the truth
it's not a smart answer i would it's a
fact you know
except except for bert really nailed it
you remember bert
no mercy burt bert yeah yeah
burt surprised me the most i guess
here's
here's a more specific character
question for you of
all of the new ensemble and cobra kai
who do you think at this point in the
show's run
is kind of the closest to being the
johnny lawrence
of cobra kai because i remember that
being a thing when it first started out
it's like miguel was probably the johnny
and robbie was probably the daniel then
i came to realize that they were both a
mixture of both of them but
i landed in a place and i'm curious if
you agree where i feel like
hawk of all the characters is probably
closest to being in johnny's position
and might have the most to specifically
learn from him
i agree with you on that i think because
hawke's trajectory from where he started
and what he's blossomed into is so
extreme but that's a
that's a that's a version of johnny but
kind of on steroids
in a way you know with the with the
mohawk and all that
um and you know you see where he comes
from i think i think the way it's
written out um
he would be the closest to johnny
lawrence and he's got a he's got a heart
under that
pointy hair and uh and he's also uh you
know kind of
a badass that's definitely one way to
describe him
i imagine he can't say anything about
season three but just to
attempt to get a couple of teases here
where do you think
johnny's head is at at the very
beginning of the season is he kind of
you know
i guess back to rock bottom well
how do i do this without giving anyway
well you saw where he was on the beach
um i could tell you i can tell you where
i felt
at the end of last season that's really
the best and that is how painful it was
really viscerally how painful it was
to hand the keys over to crease and to
see
miguel in the in the hospital and there
was this hopelessness
and there was no season three script i
didn't know where it was gonna go so the
the dead end was right there and
throwing the bottle against the car so i
kind of came into
season three at that point um you know i
think johnny's growing
and uh we wanna but he's definitely
gonna have some downs and some ups and
some downs and some ups and some
sideways
and uh yeah so i guess i i guess that's
so so you know i mean he wasn't doing
too well at the end of season two
and uh you know picks up you know a
little bit later in time after season
two
season three does so um we're going to
meet the result
of what that what those events would do
to someone like johnny lawrence
in the beginning of season three you are
very good at like
giving us something to chew on but
avoiding spoilers i have i have a little
ear bud in here and the producers and
writers are telling you all right
i'll give you a pass on this question if
you can't do the same with this one but
again
i love this ensemble and i especially
love seeing characters who
i think are going to have like an itty
bitty role grow into something so much
more
so is there a member of the cast that
you are excited to finally get to work
with
more in season three than you had before
well whether i work with them or not i
mean johnny's many times a loner
you know he's kind of on his own and
he's the man on his own path
you know trying to figure things out but
there are a lot of characters that have
been developed in season one and two
that
definitely flourish that that uh
johnny comes in contact with in a very
fun way and that absolutely was super
fun and exciting i can't wait for people
to see
i mean yeah there's some i'm trying to
hold back it's
you know i know everybody's waiting for
season three we've been waiting for
season three it's not easy to
you know see the ball kick down the
field but it's it's what has to happen
and we're just uh
you know saying thankful to our fans for
hanging with us and i
hope they invite their friends to watch
the first two and get ready for the big
ride because season three is incredible
i mean it's really incredible i was all
excited when i was one or two on
steroids but i don't wanna i don't wanna
i don't wanna say too much but
2021 though it's hey man
march was two days ago right what is it
very fair point
it's like this year's like this year
doesn't yeah okay
all right i might have some patience for
that yeah
before i let you go here i feel like
everybody out there in addition to cobra
kai
is kind of looking for content to watch
online right now and
this is a little kind of out of left
field given this conversation but what i
feel like most people don't know about
you
is that you are an academy award nominee
and you wow you have a short film that
is quite
good that people can check out so i was
wondering for you
what what was that experience like being
nominated but also i i guess to be kind
of blunt with it
you have all that success with most like
why didn't you do it again
i want to i mean i before i became an
actor i was i went to film school i
didn't go to acting school i wanted to
be a filmmaker and
gotten the karate kid my acting career
took off and then i went on the side and
i direct and produce
and this and that most was a labor love
passion project
and it was i want to do it again i
definitely want to
craft story and produce and write direct
something like that again
being nominated i could tell you was
very surreal but
in a way i can it's it's like when i did
the karate kid for example it was brand
new
and i we we wrapped in december and it
came out in june and i didn't see much
of it in between so
it's like i did my part i walked away i
went there it was on the screen it went
to the premiere and there it was
with most in a film that you're involved
with i was there every single step of
the way and it was very very difficult
to make this film
we shot in eastern europe and we left
with no money no budget no country
no no cast we want a location scout
eight countries and bit by bit found it
we found our cast we wrote it then we
got the financing for it involved 1930
steam trains and
bridges and poland and negative 10
degree weather it was really difficult
then we had a bridge break we had to go
back in the summer and reshoot it with
insurance money it was
the making of this movie took two years
for a 30 minute short
and it took a lot of me all of me and i
was completely committed to it and then
we premiered at sundance and we went on
to win all these festivals and we won
best of festival in uh palm springs
international short fest
um which opened us to be qualified for
an oscar we were on the list
and then they announced the list and it
was unbelievable you know i was like but
i guess but
i could say this place like walking the
red carpet at the oscars
was was unbelievable but it was like
i knew i was oriented in being there
because of the years that i had
spent to get there so it was kind of
like you know we were battle wounded
walking that carpet and uh
you know escorting our film to uh to the
big stage and it was
it was a thrill highlight of my life and
uh for people want to watch it you could
probably just go on youtube and type in
most the bridge
um there's many different versions that
have been uploaded it's been kind of
you know put out there but most the
bridge it's a great it's a great show
it's 33 minutes yeah it's a great watch
yeah
speaking of that though have you had any
interest in you know
maybe bringing your directing skills to
cobra guy i
have i've talked about with the guys
lately um you know that's a
that's a sensitive line when you're
working with
actors that are you know you're leaning
on to be subject of an objective at the
same time
i think in the in the future i could see
that definitely happening once
everybody's you know
everybody had to find themselves in
their positions and to be honest i have
my work cut out for me playing this
character and the many levels and the
fighting and the
you know the rehearsals and the lines i
mean the scripts come in the lines
pages of dialogue it's enough for me to
do that let alone go pick locations
cameras angles and
set shots and then you know still still
do the show so i i haven't figured out
how
i could do that yet but i hope to i hope
to
figure that trick out you got your hands
full yeah
anything you want to happen behind the
lens i hope you get the opportunity to
do it but
congratulations yet again on kai this
show
should bring me more joy than than you
know i freaking love it i so appreciate
it and you're my first interview this
year
uh and the first time i've ever talked
about season three or any of this this
year so
thank you perry thank you as always to
everybody out there
if you have watched cobra kai you can go
watch it again on netflix when both
seasons drop on
august 28th but don't forget if someone
in your life has not watched it
i would like to bet that they're going
to appreciate the recommendations so
cobra kai seasons 1 and 2 on netflix
august 28th check it out guys